remarks so this is interesting uh you  can see i'm keeping on this is a broad  brush i'm keeping a chance of rain right  through a tuesday  the best chance might be sunday night  into monday with some showers some  mountain thunderstorms on sunday maybe  an isolated rumble of thunder on  saturday i think overall i think we'll  salvage the weekend still a shot though  for some moisture tomorrow with a mix of  sun and clouds and then i think we'll  break into some sunshine on thursday but  again the atmosphere is very juicy and  it's very unstable so that could trigger  a thunderstorm overnight lows will stay  in the mid 80s so going into august a  very unsettled weather pattern i wish i  could be more precise but i think every  day you're going to have to keep your  eye to the sky that's it for weather  let's go back to kirsten and christian  thank